s'il vous plaît, levez la main droite et répétez
après moi
je joseph robinette biden jr jure solennellement
bonjour joseph robinette biden jr jure solennellement
que j'exécuterai fidèlement que
j'exécuterai fidèlement
le bureau du président des
états-unis bureau du président des états-unis
et le fera au mieux de mes capacités
au mieux de mes capacités
préserver protéger et défendre préserver
protéger
et défendre la constitution des
états-unis constitution des
états-unis alors aidez-moi Dieu
alors aidez-moi Dieu félicitations monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
président
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allons-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous